good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Thursday hope
everybody's having an amazing gorgeous
beautiful setting in smart and Wiggly
talented day
speaking of wickedly talented here's one
of the most wickedly talented girls I
know
Jax how you doing
hey Claude I'm Dern good happy Thursday
kind of feels like a Friday now I know I
didn't want to say it because I just
felt like maybe it's me but between the
fact that like we did talk shop live
last night and then you're going out to
The Hamptons today it just felt like
okay so it's Friday now yeah and I think
it's actually kind of disgusting that
it's not I think it's really
disrespectful to women and
you know the vulnerable communities in
our society I he totally agree oh my God
speaking of vulnerable
communities in our society I saw a tick
tock that like I I fear I've tick-tocked
too close to the Sun like I people on
the internet are like always complaining
about crazy things and I'd love to see
if like in the comments section people
are agreeing with them or you know being
like you're crazy
um and I saw a tick tock actually just
this morning when I was making you know
my morning dump that really kind of that
really took the cake for maybe the
craziest thing I've heard like
okay so it was this girl she was crying
and I was like oh man I wonder what
she's crying about and she was you know
um I think she was like applying for
some program or something and she was
doing an orientation and she had asked a
question if they have any accommodations
you know for her situation you know and
I thought she was going to say she's
maybe in a wheelchair like you know what
whatever her you know her uh things she
needed accommodating for and
she um has time blindness
okay
so she um has a you know she's literally
incapable of being on time
and she was wondering if the program had
any accommodations of they did not and
she said that it was like really
disgusting that the person running this
program you know is she actually said
you know holding up this construct and
contributing to a society in which they
don't accommodate for time blindness I
had never heard of time blindness before
um I was shocked honestly that it had a
name you know people who can't like I
think that's you know
people are considering themselves I
guess like disabled because that
timeliness it was shocking it has time
blindness yeah I should go a little
easier on him I didn't realize it was a
creative Jackie are you making
accommodations for your husband who like
you know what that is offensive to
people who are actually blind no no the
whole thing is so offensive and
ridiculous but people just no one wants
to be well that's the thing it's not
that everyone is unwell it's that no one
wants to be well and like being well is
not cool right now not in the slightest
and that's unfortunate and that's unwell
you know I spend a lot of time on the
internet and I end up in like really
dark corners of the internet so it takes
a lot to shock me but time blindness
like it it shook me
yeah that's crazy yeah
damn
so that's what I did this morning
um
yeah okay well don't show that to my
husband because and then he'll be like
you know
taunting me so I'm giving a doctor's
note he'll say I'm ableist when I yell
at him to get out the door Jackie's
gonna get a doctor's note
[Laughter]
um how are you doing queen I'm good
we're podcasting from home which is
necessary because we had such a big
night last night we had so much fun we
did talk shop live for my book the
camper and the counselor so it was like
a live home shopping experience it was
giving QVC and of course Claudia and
Margo were there to support me and they
made the show so fun and funny uh you
should watch this stream because that's
the one place that you can pre-order a
signed copy of the book right now but
also it's just like good old-fashioned
steeny Vibes we said it was going to be
giving freaking Fred and I think what we
gave was freaking Fred yeah freaking
Fred plus the snitch
yep and you know us we're always like
pulling the snitch out of her comfort
zone we're always a clawing for more
time with the snitch yeah so it was I
had so much fun and it was really fun
live with the community because we used
to be live swirlies every day and now
it's just a special treat and last night
was really a treat to do all the live
comments I came home and I was
re-watching and I was able to see more
comments and everyone was just so
supportive and it was a really lovely
evening
do you ever sit back and think about
like the years literal years of
thousands of episodes we did completely
live
no I don't like I can think because
honestly we could do it again not that
we actually can't because of the way our
cameras work now like technically we
can't but we don't edit our episodes
really and whenever we do like it's not
ever something that's actually crazy no
no of course not but I just can't like I
find peace knowing like you and I can
have open conversations knowing like if
I say something you know what I don't
really stand by or like maybe could get
misconstrued like I'm happy to edit it
out like that feeling and I we never
you're right we never edit our episodes
unless like no we really don't so we
still technically like do it as if it's
live but having that sort of safety net
is such a comfort and so knowing that we
used to just like go row go live like
thousands of people watching as we were
saying the things like we were so nuts
yeah no we were crazy but to be young to
be young is to be crazy so true now
we're old hags who edit our episodes and
we edit them beyond recognition letter
sometimes people sometimes we like edit
the episode you can only I guess tell on
video If there's like a cut but it's not
ever like because of something that we
said necessarily it's like
sometimes you have to pay sometimes
that's like a glitch or like or it's
like a technical thing like oh we've got
that ad there you know what I mean like
stuff like that no it's so true like
we're so we're like once again the theme
of this week like disgustingly authentic
it needs to stop I know it's like we
can't shut our mouths I know it's like
not everyone needs to know everything
you know
but we're just so authentic I literally
like but not to be so authentic no
please please I wouldn't know how to be
inauthentic really so true it's actually
easier to be authentic
yeah and that's why like whenever you
know people say all crazy things about
us but whenever people say like I met or
I saw you know Jackie and Claude and
they were so mean like that's just it's
literally impossible
yeah I didn't know anyone who said that
I saw somebody say like this is how I
know people make up about me like I
saw somebody say once I saw Claudia once
walking her dog and she was just like so
like had this nasty look on her face she
looked so miserable like she's not a
nice person first of all like if when
I'm walking my dog um I am miserable
like I'd rather be in bed second of all
you didn't even talk to me like how did
you glean that I'm a miserable nasty
person I'm literally minding my own
goddamn business you
you know people are nuts
nuts so first the time blindness and now
this
yeah well we shouldn't be time blind
today because we have shed we have a lot
to discuss we have some interesting
stories the stories are giving Friday
I'm telling you there's something in the
air today Jax it's all around us I know
it's really exciting and what's really
exciting for me not so much for you is
that I have Bryson streis with me in bed
right now because Claudia is leaving
Theo with me for the weekend so she can
go galavant about town and Theo's
staying with his Auntie Jackie has so
graciously agreed to watch Theo I can't
really you know stress how nice it is to
you know be able to enjoy my weekend
knowing that Theo will be in the loving
arms of Brew Harry
Auntie Jax Uncle Zach like it's such a
joy I can't thank you enough for
watching my son and I know you watch him
with great care I do I wouldn't say
he'll be in Bruno's Loving Arms though
no he'll be in Bruno's jealous Webb yeah
no it's not a great weekend to be Bruno
no I mean but it is like he's mommy's
Angel he knows
now he's very threatened by like the
other furry lovers in in your life and
what doesn't help Bruno's situation is
that Harry adores Theo I know and
obviously Harry loves Bru like love of
course but like when he sees Theo it's
Father's father like No And it's like
it's so easy for you know Theo to just
come in every now and then and be
beloved by Harry like Bruno has to do
the hard stuff you know Bruno's there
when it's not easy and and Theo just
kind of walks in it's like you know the
fun Uncle like of course you're gonna
love the fun uncle but the fun uncle is
not the one raising you no not the one
changing diapers not the one taking hits
and getting toys thrown at him like he's
just the one who's like standing under
the high chair waiting for dinner crumbs
yeah so I I do I understand the plight
of Bruno but if I could say to one thing
to Bruno it would be you know Theo's
away from home this weekend should I use
my airpod out so he can hear you yeah
like he's the one who needs your love
and attention if you could just Embrace
him that would mean a lot to your auntie
and you love your auntie Bruno right so
what do you want to make her happy it's
true and Bruno I would say to you
remember all the times that you've
stayed by Auntie when she sheltered you
when you were displaced and however when
I prioritize him that you felt right at
home and felt just like as loved as Theo
right
it's your turn to pay it forward Brew
it's your turn to be the big bro it's
true I know he'll rise to the occasion
do keep us updated throughout the
weekend Oh I will you can follow me on
Instagram and watch my stories I'm just
going to be posting pictures of the dogs
all weekend
um that sounds like an amazing weekend I
cannot lie yeah no just like all the
Swirls and different swirly situations
yeah just kind of swirling around the
world they are so swirly I mean Theo's
not as swirly as Bruno Bruno is always
in a cinnamon swirl yeah Theo has many
positions he likes to lie in sometimes
he likes to you know spread them he
loves those he loves a sploot he loves
to lay on his belly legs out yes but he
does also love a swirl but it's not his
go-to number one position all the time
yeah Thea Bruno is like
the swirlier the girlier we were having
this conversation over the weekend
um
about how swirly has just become like a
word that we are obsessed with and there
is an origin story it's a deep-rooted
family story it is that doesn't paint
one of our sisters like in the most
amazing light so we're not gonna share
it but just know when you're because
everyone has started saying girls we're
like just know when you're saying it the
history and the origin of the story is
so good and if we were one eight one day
able to tell the story it would really
be the funniest thing you guys ever
heard in your life but we just we can
yeah just know it's a good story and
we're just protecting our family by not
saying it you guys understand that yeah
we haven't gotten approval to share the
story I haven't even asked because I
know it's a no
[Laughter]
and if I was the person who originated
the swirly story like I would say
absolutely not so like I get it yeah
and I guess we'll stop talking about the
story that you guys can't hear now yeah
it's like so annoying of us it's giving
secret project oh my God the swirly is
my secret project
literally the swirly is a secret project
that was the first secret project oh my
god did we invent secret projects we did
I'm obsessed damn okay
speaking of secret projects make sure to
pre-order my book the camper and the
counselor you can get it anywhere you
pre-order books but if you want to
pre-order a signed copy head over to my
talk shop live link it's in my stories
it's in my bio
um it's MSRP pricing 18.99 so you know
the signature is relatively free not you
giving like you know MSRP like what are
you a car dealership I just think love I
love MSRP I don't know what it stands
for but like me neither it's like retail
pricing yeah no like when we do our
Merchant stuff they're always like the
MSRP and we me and Jack are just like oh
okay yeah sure of course
I mean how could you not even How Could
You Forget the Miss rip yeah I
personally would never also it will be
like a first edition signed copy
collector's item you just never know
like how that's gonna age in value so
true it's an investment in your future
you guys and I'm all about making
Investments we know
so
check it out
so without further
and without further Ado but I'm covered
in dues today
except I actually don't know where Theo
is I can't see him from my perch do you
have like a bench or something at the
edge of your bed no but I have the
stairs oh no I'm just saying Theo's new
thing is he like lives to sleep under
the bench under our bed in front of our
bed oh good to know don't worry about
him he'll hope he's finding a place to
swirl up and curl up he's fine okay
without further Ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
today's episode is brought to you by
State Farm the State Farm personal price
plan helps you create a plan that gives
you options so you get an affordable
price and it comes with lots of benefits
like the coverage you want a policy that
helps cover what's important to you and
an affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences and so
many things in life are so deeply
personal comedy food poetry Insurance
think about it like this what do your
music playlist podcast feeds and social
media Scrolls all have in common well
they're a reflection of you so we all
know my social media are full of you
know time blindness Taylor Swift
theories
um and Jackie's is a little different
because you want to know why we're
different girls and that's what the
State Farm personal price plan has it
gives you options to help you
personalize your coverage so that you
can protect what you care about most at
an affordable price just for you so you
can see more of yourself in everything
that you love like a good neighbors
State Farm is there
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary you know I can't
recommend the personal price plan enough
from State Farm because like I would say
you know Jackie oh you're getting
Insurance get me one because we're so
similar I would just assume we'd have
the same plan but we don't because State
Farm knows how Personal Insurance can be
so call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan again prices vary by state option
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary today's episode is
also brought to you by article summer is
on its way have you been dreaming up
ideas for your outdoor space and how to
make the most of it well check out
article because the best thing about
summer is getting to do all of your
favorite indoor things out to outdoor
you can make meals watch movies fall
asleep on the sofa you know summertime
really reminds us that everything is
truly better Alfresco so if you have an
outdoor space in your apartment or your
house whether it's a patio a balcony a
backyard whatever it is a front porch oh
I love a front porch
um it's that time of year where like if
you've been putting off getting
furniture or getting the ottoman you
need to put your legs up head over to
article they have everything you need
for your outdoor Alfresco space article
believes in delightful design for every
home and thanks to their online only
model they have some really delightful
pricing too they have a curated
assortment of mid-century modern Coastal
industrial scandi and boho designs that
make your furniture shopping simple
their team of designers are all about
finding the perfect balance between
style quality and price you know Jackie
is blessed enough to have like a
gorgeous outdoor vibe in her home and I
was actually there when she had
Furniture delivered from article
to make her space her own and it was
such a seamless really easy very good
communication delivery you know
stress-free environment that we really
enjoyed it and their knowledgeable
customer care team is there when you
need them to make sure your experience
is smooth and stress-free which hours
was hours like I said if it's my house
article is offering our listeners 50 off
their first purchase of a hundred
dollars or more so to claim that visit
article.com toast and the discount will
be automatically applied at checkout
that's article.com toast for 50 off your
first purchase of 100 or more
article.com toast
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
first story The ESPYs were last night
yeah and headline news for people of our
elk is that Alex Earl and Braxton
Barrios make their red carpet debut
following the breakup drama with Sophia
colbo no this is crazy social media
Fanatics pop culture all coming together
at once there's always a lot of that at
the ESPYs actually yes the ESPYs are
like low-key really like in tune with
what's necessary yeah but like also so
many athletes like date stars that we
get a lot in our community yeah I don't
know like what the rules are for like
who gets invited to the ESPYs but I'm
fairly certain Braxton Barrios is like
not someone who would be invited
um under normal circumstances I'm
actually which is hilarious fairly
certain he was there as Alex's plus one
which is just really it's nice for him
because you know he plays on the
Dolphins he's not you know like the Star
Quarterback dating you know the
cheerleader like he's kind of
benchwarmer energy and I don't know if
Benchwarmers get invited to the ESPYs
it's such a good point who gets invited
to the ESPYs and why or maybe like if
you are an athlete you could swing an
invite to the ESPYs like if you work
your agent hard enough but you know how
many it's not like the NFL honors it's
NFL NBA like it's all sports no I know
but maybe most not most people but a lot
of people probably don't want to go like
they don't live in LA like it's an award
show they're not doing I disagree
they're not athletes so that they can
like walk red carpets no I disagree like
it's the off season for football it's an
off season for basketball like you know
when you're actually during the season
and I think that's why a lot of baseball
players don't go to the ESPYs because
they're currently in season you can't
really do much when you're in season
like you're training practicing playing
traveling like there's it's so it's a
lot so there's a lot of benefits to
being a famous athlete but you know
going out and about during the season
isn't one of those things so this is an
opportunity for them to like be Glam
with their girlies and walk the carpet I
think like it's actually pretty you know
competitive to get invited I've had to
assume okay well I would love it hold on
Ben just walked in Ben why don't
baseball players go to the ESPYs because
that's not the question it's currently
in no I was just wondering
irrelevant because they're oh bentos the
SPs are relevant
baseball a baseball okay doesn't have
players okay okay yeah I hear what
you're saying no there are so many
players on so many teams like you need
to ask him who who and how gets invited
to the SBS okay I would say if Alex are
on Braxton were there who got him yeah
who got invited yeah okay man so how do
they like decide which athletes from all
the leagues get to go is it like the
ones who are most famous most popular
popular popularity contest now let me
ask you one more question so Alex Earl
went because she's Alex Earl and she
went with Braxton Barrios do you think
Braxton Barrios like was there as her
plus one yes yes okay that's what I
thought too yeah he said no way okay ask
Ben does he know who Braxton Barrios is
like good question as a football player
okay then do you know who Braxton
Barrios is slash was like before he
became like a I had heard of him he had
heard of him does he play well does he
play like does he get minutes on the on
the field he does is he good
he's yeah okay so maybe he got invited
no he definitely didn't get invited on
his own okay anyways but any player can
go by the way why don't you come into
the microphone come to the microphone
that was important what he said yeah
like like if a player wants to go and
they ask the SPs I highly doubt the
ESPYs are going to turn down a
professional player that wants to come
but there are only so many seats in that
theater yeah so maybe he didn't wouldn't
have had a seat but he still could have
come okay like walk the carpet yeah like
think about like uh the Oscars or
something like every single person
that's a part of a movie is entitled to
come to some part of it doesn't mean
that they're like sitting in the
orchestra when they're handing out the
awards but like you know like those that
like random movie that wins nine times
they have like the assistant of the
person who designs costume that goes on
stage right right no that's a good point
I think
have to do with if the team was good
yeah it depends on like your team's
standing he's saying like in League yes
okay
this is very interesting thank you so
a couple posts for photos together at
the awards uh she wore strapless leather
dress with Steve Madden heels relatable
Queen and her hair oh wow into a half Up
Style
wow not the Steve Madden shoes on the
red carpet so what do you think that was
like a like a product placement
no I do
yeah Steve Madden shoes because it's in
the article yeah
good marketing on Steve Madden's part
and get your coin Alex roll yeah I think
it's that the fact that she was invited
is fabulous I think it's like really
good for you know people like us to care
about the ESPYs it's good marketing and
then of course her dating an athlete is
um pertinent here now I hope she was you
know out mingling maybe meeting other
athletes because I do feel like in terms
of like the athletic world like she
could date someone who's like a little
better at sports you know
you know they're kind of like both young
up and coming good looking live in Miami
like what more could you want out of a
relationship at this age
yeah but like you know she Rose to
stardom she's in a very unique position
where like she could be really like she
could date Tom Brady if she wanted like
let's aim higher
but what about love what if she loves
him What About Love okay what about
sometimes you don't consider love
like do you think she would love Tom
Brady genuinely
yes I think what really truly anyone
could you what if he's a tarturer
no but if he's like the worst
personality I'm sure he does because you
don't get tens across the board in life
like you don't get to be like the best
quarterback of all time and also be like
the most interesting dinner party guest
that everyone wants to talk to and the
most handsome all he cares about is
football and his friends and his mom
is that bad no that's for Mean Girls no
that's literally what she says it
responds
[Laughter]
I was finishing your quote it's a really
good good
like all he cares is it football
baseball and his mom
um yeah is that bad I guess it doesn't
leave room for a girlfriend is what I
was trying to say no no I think the
point of that line is like Regina was
deeply unwell
like like that is like all he cares
about are like something like a sport
like a hobby a passion of his his family
and his mom like dream man
yeah but she was saying he doesn't care
about her and that's a problem who could
who could she was the devil yeah
who could so back to Alex and Braxton
also I feel like they've had like kind
of a tumultuous month with all of the
Sofia the drama with Sophia and you do
sometimes think that that could like Mar
a relationship but so early on
but they're going strong still and
they're doubling down with you know a
red carpet appearance right this was
their first like they've been spotted
out in public together but not on a red
carpet this is like an official and I
think the last time when they were like
spotted out she um had responded that
like they're seeing each other they're
not like but this is giving boyfriend
girlfriend energy it's giving you know
to find the relationship yeah also like
he was in her Vlog last month
she gave him like a hug on the bed
yeah like it was like we did this and we
did that we we've been knowing you know
we know yeah so they're together they
look nice I hope they had a nice night
yeah it must be just so fun to be Alex
Earl right now totally picture you think
she's like a little exhausted
no I think sometimes I guess since she
just came from college like that really
prepares you for a whirlwind life yeah
and also just being young like you have
a lot of energy I also think like when
people have these rise to fame moments
like certain people are built for it and
some people are not and I get the
feeling that Alex Earl is built for it I
agree with you it gives like you know
and I think when we watch that first
season of the demilio show one of my
takeaways was perhaps these girls
because they're so young are not built
for it you know they're not built for it
age-wise but also just temperament wise
they're not right that's what I was
thinking too but Alex is not is
different I I agree she potentially has
the stuff to go for this yeah like kind
of made for it so that's that's just my
purview you know as a completely
objective third-party Outsider with no
particular interest in the matter truly
are you ready for our next story yes the
inner pump rules scores their first ever
Emmy nomination after scandival
s has been nominated for two Emmy Awards
following the gripping Saga of Tom and
Raquel's shocking Affair aka scandival
the hit Bravo series which hit an
all-time high viewership during season
10 scored two nominations for the 2023
awards show outstanding unstructured
reality program and outstanding picture
editing for an unstructured reality
program
um did their competition
um for unsure for outstanding
unstructured reality program they'll be
up against Indian matchmaking RuPaul's
Drag Race selling Sunset and welcome to
wrexham and then for the other
nomination there against Deadliest Catch
Life Below Zero RuPaul's Drag Race and
welcome to wrexham
yet these categories I feel like
RuPaul's Drag Race usually sweeps like
that show has like 40 Emmys in their
Arsenal
um I just like don't get me wrong I love
Vanderpump girls I've been watching it
since its Inception but like don't you
feel like perhaps you know we've hit a
low when Vanderpump Rules is nominated
for Emmys do you know what I mean I do
know what you mean and I feel like
really two ways about this because on
the one hand it's like the Emmys are
meant to be like a prestigious Awards
like what is going on on the other hand
like if you look at what else is
nominated and wins Emmys it's like not
actually the most popular or the best
television it's just like you know
Industries people jerking each other off
and like this was the most popular
outstanding unstructured reality program
award like if you want to be in the game
you kind of have to nominate it but to
me like what's more shocking is that in
this category selling Sunset is not yeah
and I saw that too and that's like
should be the headline news because
that's absolutely disgraceful I
completely agree with there's not one
even at its height
there is not one thing about selling
Sunset that is Emmy worthy and it's not
a reality show it's not a reality show
no one there is even a broker like it
shouldn't even be nominated for People's
Choice Award it should be eligible for
scripted like it's literally not real no
but even if you want to put in scripted
like the plot if you could even say that
they have one are horrible thin at best
oh my God like there was a whole season
about something that happened nine years
ago outside of a gym between Emma and
Christine's boyfriend like yeah that's
shocking I completely agree that's
shocking so given that like selling
Sunset could be in the mix then
Vanderpump Rules of course 100 be
nominated no that's fair I mean the Emmy
nominations that came out yesterday were
you know a lot of what's expected but
was what was funny was like a lot of the
um
the categories for like supporting
actors supporting actress were literally
five different people from two different
shows it was like everyone from
succession and everyone from White Lotus
oh wow do you want to go through the
Emmy nominations
I guess but like quickly we could go
through the big categories I hadn't
planned on it but whatever
one drama series and or better call
sorrow the crown House of the Dragon The
Last of Us succession the White Lotus
Yellowjackets so all of them yeah comedy
series Abbott Elementary Barry the bear
jury duty The Marvelous Mrs maisel only
murders in the building Ted lasso
Wednesday yeah sure I mean they Gotta
Give It Up With The Marvelous Miss
maisel like I'm a fan of the show I've
watched it since the beginning I'm like
it is not good like it's not Emmy worthy
this is the last year that it will be
like constantly in our faces No I know
but I
like watch it and it's not good
yeah
next limited series beef Dahmer Daisy
Jones and the six Fleischman is in
trouble Obi-Wan Kenobi
yeah it was a good it was a good uh day
yesterday for the daisy Jones peeps
because you know they were campaigning
hard on social media like give Daisy uh
let me know let me know for your
consideration and she got it and so did
Cami I don't think that it
deserved to be nominated for a limited
series me neither but I think that if
anyone from the show deserved to be
nominated it was Cami Marone not Riley
Keough but you know they both got it oh
they did both get it yeah cool lead
actor in a drama series Jeff Bridges the
old man Brian Cox succession Kieran
Culkin's succession Bob Odenkirk Better
Call Saul Pedro Pascal The Last of Us
Jeremy Strong succession
great everyone's obsessed with Pedro
Pascal and The Last of Us yes Pedro
pascals you're also like saying his name
beyond weird I didn't realize who you
were talking about until I said you said
for Pascal you were just like Pedro
Pascal like you said it weird like rope
okay Pedro Pascal yes he's having a
moment yeah
lead actress in a drama series Sharon
Hogan bad sisters Melanie lynskey the
Yellowjackets Elizabeth Moss handmaid's
tale Bella Ramsey The Last of Us Carrie
Russell the Diplomat Sarah Snook's
succession
not that I've seen all these shows I've
actually only seen one of them but this
just feels like kind of like a week
showing yeah yeah no standouts lead
actor in a comedy series Bill Hader
Barry Jason Siegel shrinking Martin
Short only murders in the building Jason
Sudeikis Ted lasso Jeremy Allen White
the bear
no comment I'm not getting into the bear
again I don't need to get canceled on a
Friday even though it's Thursday
actress in a comedy
Rachel Brosnahan maisel kinta Brunson
Abbott Elementary Natasha Leone Poker
Face Jenna Ortega Wednesday
I just no I'm telling you them like a
decent amount of the shows that are
nominated probably maybe half and I just
like really don't have a horse in the
race
yeah I just want to say if you're
listening to these Emmy nominations and
you just heard a flush in the background
my husband's an animal like I don't know
how many times I have to say I'm
podcasting like not him Flushing
so rude he doesn't want you to succeed
to succeed he's trying to sabotage so
that good he's trying to sabotage us yes
guys don't listen to good guys listen to
the toast the good guys don't respect
the toast
then staring at me major beef no it's
disgusting Flushing
so I didn't hear it I doubt it picked up
on the mic okay
okay Ben said but everyone should listen
to good guys get out get out get out
seriously go you're late we're gonna be
let go that's psychotic if Zach was
standing here while I was podcasting
like I would be throwing things at him
same if only Ben wasn't so unfortunately
beloved by this community I would have
thrown him out but every episode he's in
it's just like the numbers keep going up
and he did make himself useful do you
think that for today we could say like
whatever the title is featuring
featuring men's offer
let's not give him you know like credit
no but we are women in business let's
use him
let's milk him for all he's worth
I like that Nobby hi hi it's crazy how
like little I care about the Emmy
nominations can we move on like I'm
sorry I even brought it up for sure also
George and Tammy should have been
nominated for a limited series because
you know like a lot of things young
Sheldon young Sheldon Michael Shannon
and Jessica Chastain were nominated for
the leads in limited series
they were good enough but the show
wasn't good enough I don't think so
where's young Sheldon like if young
children's not gonna nominate for an
Emmy like I don't want to watch
yeah
I didn't get to watch it anymore
oh I did because Zach wasn't here so I
would oh my God he would have been so
upset if I watched without him I'm like
the joy I feel that you guys are loving
young Sheldon like it's it's like
actually a show that's like deeply
special to me no it's it's incredibly
special I'm so glad it's a special show
so much so that I know that I won't do
this but like it's occurred to me
maybe try check out the Big Bang Theory
okay so of course I had similar thoughts
and me and Ben watched first episode and
Ben and his family like they're always
whenever I think of Big Bang Theory I
think of this offers like they like it I
know Ben's sister loves it so I'm like
okay you know what
let's give it a shot we watch the first
episode it's literally horrible like
Sheldon is literally like old Sheldon
he's insufferable he cannot carry a show
like his character like I could
literally see them kill the character
there's like a bunch but yes it's like
him and his friends and his roommates
but what about Kaylee Cuoco
she lives across the hall
and it's not about her no it is it's
like about it's like it's an ensemble
show it's like friends it's like friends
so young Sheldon is like yeah it's like
nerdy friends Sheldon's like Ross you
know he's just one of the main got it I
might give it a chance Dana loves it but
she would because she is young Sheldon
yeah Dana loves young Sheldon too some
maybe I'll give it another shot but like
honestly and that stupid theme
song the whole universe is
by the way what are your thoughts on the
young Sheldon theme song because I have
a lot I had it in my head last night I
like it I think it's like so nice Mighty
little man what's with the cow
yeah I feel like the the theme song is
like the one thing that doesn't fit in
the show like it's like a rock
song it's so loud I always have to like
mute the TV and it honestly in the
beginning used to really bother me so
much so to the point like I couldn't
watch the show I'm like this theme song
I'd like grab the clicker the second the
episode was over like it bothered me so
much really dramatic
now I'm obsessed like whenever it comes
on we don't skip it me and Ben sing it
and I've actually learned how to
harmonize I am a mighty little man like
I'm obsessed
that's just proof like if you stick with
something long enough like you can love
anything no but I like this song I would
maybe agree with you that it's misplaced
but it's like
it's a good song it kind of reminds me
of the Ted lasso theme song where it's
like oh okay and now Mumford and Sons
are here
I guess I I just I I don't think it's
right I don't think it fits
it's cute
it's Relic show
[Laughter]
are you ready for our next story which
is some more TV news yeah
a sag after a strike is imminent as
talks conclude with no deal a sag after
strike appears to be imminent as talks
with the Studios have concluded without
a deal or an extension the Union's
contract officially expired at midnight
in a statement the union said that the
negotiating committee had voted
unanimously to recommend a strike the
Union's national board is expected to
meet Thursday morning to call a strike
which would immediately halt scripted
film and TV production by the companies
represented by the alliance of motion
picture and television producers Fran
Drescher who's the president yes of sag
said in a statement that the amptp's
responses to its key issues were
insulting and disrespectful sag
negotiated in good faith and was eager
to reach a deal that sufficiently
addressed performer needs but the
amptp's responses to the Union's most
important proposals have been insulting
and disrespectful of our massive
contributions to this industry the
companies have refused to meaningfully
engage on some topics and on others
completely stoned wall to us until they
do negotiate in good faith we cannot
begin to reach a deal
I um throughout this process of the
writer strike have learned that Fran
Drescher is the president of the
sag-aftra and I'd love to see you know
an absolute Queen you know being a
leader in her community I'm so I'm in
awe of her
to be honest I don't like know
everything that like the the battle
between the SAG and many other bigwigs
is about
um I know it's about you know streaming
rights and like getting paid better yeah
what's it called when you get residuals
Street residuals
um something about AI like not being
able to take their jobs I think is also
an issue for them and anyway so like I'm
kind of unclear on the specificities but
like if Francis like throwing her weight
behind something like I stand with Fran
no I stand with an Annie she literally
raised me
um and not to make everything about me
but I totally forgot to tell you this
yesterday I found myself in the middle
of the writers strike
um how do you find a way to make it
about you I went to I had to I had like
a video shoot on 49th between like sixth
and seventh and I get out of the Uber
and like the building that I'm going in
there was literally picketers like
outside with their signs oh wow it
wasn't a great showing it might have
been six people they didn't feel like
really honestly like what I gleamed was
that like the writers might be buckling
under the pressure there weren't a lot
of people there
interesting but what's interesting also
was like I feel like everyone's on the
side of the writers you know there's
really no other side there's I know so
there's like no other faces on the other
side but you know who's like coming out
swinging from the other side
who Bob Iger
why because he's a Disney boss like he's
the the big wig who's like going up
against Saturday yeah so actors are now
going to be joining the writer strike
um which will completely bring Hollywood
to a halt and Bob igers is slamming the
actors who are threatening to go on
strike he said not Bob Iger getting
political he said sag abstract is not
being realistic in its demands and is
being disruptive to the already
struggling industry amid the ongoing
writers strike oh this is tough two
people I deeply admire going
head-to-head Fran Drescher versus Bob
Iger I never saw thought I'd see the day
but damn you know Bob Iger I trust him
like I trust that he's a good you know
business person so I don't know yeah
it's confusing and there hasn't been a
double strike of actors and writers in
Hollywood since 1960.
um her story in the making just thought
you should know
you know but this is the time when like
actors and writers who are not a part of
sag like they wait for moments like this
because they're like the only employable
people when there are strikes so
if you've been thinking about maybe
writing a TV show and you can't get into
sag or whatever this might be your time
I don't know honey maybe it's our time
to do one Red Pilot to do what I don't
know no me neither and then people would
be mad at us for not standing with the
writers you know
I know but we gotta look out for number
one yeah you gotta get your coin yeah so
the the pilot that I've been thinking
about writing maybe maybe now's my time
aren't you a member of the SAG
I was briefly
um actually no I wasn't I was eligible
for sag when I filmed a commercial for I
think it was like Miller Lite or
something like a million years ago and
it was so much paperwork and it was like
three grand in dues and I was doing it
just to say I was in sag
but then I was like I'm not paying three
grand now that three grand of course
goes towards your insurance and
everything but I had insurance so I was
like it wasn't a good Financial move for
me got it well this could be your time
yeah I do think that if I had become a
member of sag it was many years ago that
you have to keep working in Sag projects
to like keep yourself eligible for the
membership I think it would have um like
I would have been booted
got it and so if you were to put
yourself forth It's like a non-sag
artist what what kind of role would you
be looking for
I'd like to be I want to be a star so I
want leading roles Silver Screen I want
it all I wanted oh
I want it I want it
the fame and the fortune you know I Want
It All I Do
okay well just putting that out there
for you
yeah I'm putting that out there for
other people you know like I'm not
scrupled so if you need a leading lady
who's not going to be a problem you know
that's me
oh okay well we'll see what happens I
mean this is eventually going to affect
all of us when there's less to watch on
TV in you know some months and years
yeah but it's a great time to to start
being a reader it's also a great time to
like start having a daily podcast that
you listen to and then you could also
watch most of the days that's what I
love about podcasting there's no unions
you know I don't gotta fight with anyone
to get my own uh paycheck up I just
gotta
just gotta do the damn thing
we're free women it could be a big
moment for podcasting
yeah because podcasting is kind of like
a free market it is first it's an open
market for now well just wait till they
start unionizing well now with like all
these like big companies like scooping
things up It's Gonna Change it's gonna
change the field a little bit but we're
independent squirrelies we are we're
independent contractors so you don't
have to worry about us
you don't
are you ready for our next story no
because our next story is brought to you
by Skylight frames you ever missed your
loved ones when you aren't together do
they miss you well here's a gift that
brings you all together no matter how
far apart you live a skylight frame the
Skylight frame is a touch screen photo
frame that your whole family can email
photos to and they'll appear in seconds
you get to share your favorite moments
with the people that matter most to you
one of the most devastating things not
to make everything about me one of the
most devastating things that ever
happened to me was two of my sisters
moving cross country taking the kids
with them and just like never to be seen
or heard from again
now it would be even more devastating
had we not had a skylight frame to keep
us all in touch it was so easy to set up
we all could like be a part of it send
pictures of the kids it's really a great
way to stay in touch it's a great gift
for parents someone with a birthday
coming up someone who just had a baby
new grandparents or even just for
yourself anyone can send photos to the
frame in just seconds via email or an
app so it's a great way to keep in touch
with friends and family it's so simple
to use the setup takes less than 60
seconds and even the least tech savvy
person can use it it looks like a real
photo frame so it has a beautiful touch
to your home and it holds thousands of
photos that continuously rotate
throughout the day and bring daily Joy
this quiet Skylight frame has a gorgeous
touch screen that comes in two sizes the
original 10 inch and the new 15-inch
Gallery frame they have 100 satisfaction
guarantee so you don't if you don't love
your Skylight they'll send you a full
refund as a special offer for our
listeners get 15 off your purchase of a
skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com toast that's 15 off
your purchase of a skylight frame when
you go to skylightframe.com toast
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com slash
toast time goes fast staying in touch
with those we love is more important
than ever and now the Skylight frame
makes it easy and fun today's episode is
also brought to you by better sleep we
all want to feel ready to conquer our
day when we wake up but we've got a lot
on our minds and it's tough to get the
rest that we need with the better sleep
app you can personalize the Sleep
experience that calms your racing
thoughts and boosts concentration in
fact Business Insider says better sleep
is one of the most positively reviewed
apps in the history of the Apple Store
so better sleep is basically your tool
kit for improved rest I've been
struggling so much with sleep like over
the last couple of weeks it's so
annoying nothing like ruins your daily
flow your schedule more than just not
being able to fall or stay asleep so the
better sleep app has over 200 soothing
sounds and a range of Smart features to
help you sleep faster deeper and for
longer you can use a pre-made soundscape
mix or combine your favorite sounds
color noises and Melodies From better
sleep's expansive library to create your
perfect mix it's an award-winning app
that works what I love about it is they
have such a big range
of sleep experiences so it's backed by
Sleep Experts and science they have high
quality
um
sounds and they know that rest is vital
to mental well-being and to physical
health better sleep collaborated with
world-renowned sleep specialists and
Oxford University Professor Dr Russell
Foster to help you achieve your best
sleep clear your mind and ease your
stress with expert guided meditations
and hypnosis also what I really love and
what I use is their ASMR because I love
ASMR when you sleep better you feel
better improve your quality of life in
as little as one week download better
sleep from the app store or Google Play
It's called better sleep
b-e-t-t-e-r sleep s-l-e-e-p on the app
store or Google Play
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
next story is very sad Corey Monteith
was honored by Leah Michelle on the 10th
anniversary of his death she said I miss
you every day a decade after Cory
Monteith's Unexpected death at age 31
his former love Leah Michelle is
remembering the impact he had on her
life
she posted a sweet photo of them and
wrote hey you 10 years It Feels Like
Only Yesterday that you were here and
yet a million years ago all at the same
time I hold all of our memories in my
heart where they will stay safe and
never forgotten we miss you every day
and will never forget the light you
brought to us all I miss you big guy I
hope you found Taylor up there and are
playing the drums together which is a
reference to the Foo Fighters drummer
Taylor Hawkins who died unexpectedly in
March 2022.
you know there's a few days a year like
I know we're gonna be you know inundated
with a Corey Monteith tribute from Lea
Michelle and you know his birthday the
anniversary of his death and you know it
doesn't get any easier as a Gleek as a
Leah and Corey Stan as just a Leah Stan
it's difficult and I love that she
continues to honor him you know because
time has moved on and she's married and
she's a baby but you know it was the
first thing I saw when I opened
Instagram this morning and it was
it was a devastating blow yeah it's
really sad but it's really sad she keeps
him like
at the four and like alive through with
all the fans and just reminding everyone
because otherwise I wouldn't have
realized it was the 10-year anniversary
me neither
no
um then I was obviously like put on
Corey Monteith talk this morning and it
was so interesting somebody had put
together like all the tweets from
celebrities who had tweeted when they
heard about Corey Monteith's death and
it was really wide-ranging like Kendall
and Kylie and Kim all posted Taylor
Swift of course who had you know rumored
to me in a relationship with him Rihanna
Demi Lovato like they all took to
Twitter to be like wow I cannot believe
I'm so sad rest in peace like it was
really it was an interesting Roundup oh
wow Taylor was rumored to be in a
relationship with him
yes the and the speak now era like a lot
of the ball songs people are speculating
some to be about Corey mine mine is
about Corey
whoa are there any photos of them
together ever yes oh my God I'm on my
way yeah it's kind of like an underrated
relationship of Taylor's
yeah and I guess people like don't maybe
talk about it in the same way they talk
about her other relationships just
because
I think it was really like playing this
picture of them at that award show yeah
and then also she she cozied up to him
according to the Daily Mail I think
they're at a bowling alley
yeah it was like a brief romance and
they're hugging they're hugging at the
bowling alley I think people also think
Timeless is about him
we would have been timeless
perhaps like now that I'm seeing it
through the lens of someone who's passed
away like
yeah
damn
well if I I feel like I'm not the only
one who didn't know that no it's
definitely an underrated factoid yeah
thanks for sharing you're welcome
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yes Switching gears some exciting
news from one of Claudia's favorite
people
Claire Crawley and her husband are
expecting their first child via
surrogate Claire Carly is expecting her
first child with her husband Ryan
Dawkins via surrogate the former
Bachelorette made the announcement
Wednesday in a video shared to her
Instagram in which she and her husband
hung up a baby onesie that read worth
the wait she said our laundry is about
to get a whole lot cuter in 2024. this
is truly what my dreams are made of I
can't tell you how hard it has been to
hold the secret in as I've shared the
last 10 years of my life with you all
this was one Journey that that Ryan and
I have been keeping close to our hearts
as we navigated the uncertain world of
IVF and all that comes with it up until
this point but she will be sharing
everything from now on in the surrogacy
journey yeah I was going to say I
believe she is pregnant via surrogate
I'm really happy for her um I feel like
she had like kind of like a tumultuous
time in the spotlight and she's like
very pulled back from that now
um I didn't realize that she got married
which I'm so happy for because I feel
like even though she was you know our
chaotic player like I think she
genuinely wanted to be married and
settle down and like have a family so
badly I and sometimes that like she made
the wrong decisions because of it like
running away with Dale and not trusting
the process and everything but like this
is really what she's always wanted and
I'm really happy that she's found it me
too the announcement was giving tied
commercial I literally thought it was an
ad at first for like Bounty
um or bounce because it was just like
fresh Linens fresh linens on the
clothesline yeah um but I am really
happy for her maybe like the sponsorship
fell through at the last minute and they
were like I was let's just post it I was
thinking like this would be a perfect
opportunity you know for gain or downy
unscented to get in there and you know
bring their basics
Branch Basics maybe she like kind of
filmed like this generic laundry
commercials baby announcement and
pitched it so that anyone could come in
and put their name on it you know it was
you know I feel like it's hard to stand
out in pregnancy announcements when it
comes to social media so this was a
different angle and I commend her for
doing something different I didn't think
that hard about it but you're right it's
not
the typical
no like the the laundry angle was
different I liked it the laundry's about
to get a lot cuter Claude
and it was worth the wait you see that
the onesie said worth the wait yeah
really really cute I'm happy for her
you're right like she's so almost to the
point of like desperation I think was
like so eager to settle down and just
like start that part of her life that it
definitely blinded her in her journey on
The Bachelor
um but she really came from a good place
like she was chaotic but she's really a
sweet nice girl
as they come on The Bachelor like so
true too fine love period yeah it's so
true so I really wish the best for her
yeah also it was reminding me of like
her her season her her two episodes of
with Dale which is so crazy that they
did that yeah
and it's
it's crazy because it didn't work out
like if they had really like trusted
that like this was their moment and like
ran away together and we're still
married oh my God
so funny you know what I'm saying about
last night because I could not sleep
such an underrated like fact do you
remember when we had on our show like a
million years ago Ashley H from The
Bachelorette
yeah
and we tried to get her to remember like
who I was
and she was my camp counselor that was
just like a crazy time like how the girl
like she was my campaign I feel like
I've told that story in a while like
maybe people don't know like Ashley H
from The Bachelor like early early days
who I believe is still married to her
Bachelor person right yeah she was my
counselor in Camp when I was like eight
or nine she was so cool she was a dance
instructor she was like the best yeah
and then she ended up coming on our show
and we didn't tell her that she was my
camp counselor so we sat her down we
were like do you remember me and she was
like no no and she definitely didn't and
honestly why would she like no there
were so many campers and like I was not
special no and then maybe if you showed
her a picture of you as a camper
oh yeah I literally gained like 65
pounds I was like so much different
looking like why would she remember me
65.
um and we put her we like put her
on the spot and we were like in her face
like do you know who I am literally she
was probably terrible and she tried so
hard she tried so hard to remember but
could you imagine someone did that to
you
jail
jail people I feel like people actually
do that sometimes to you and you're like
no
happens all the time it happens all the
time it's a weird thing to do to people
just tell them how you know them yeah
yeah do you remember Ray
[Laughter]
and I'm like
me remember something though I don't
remember anything yeah let's stop that
collectively even though actually that
did just happen to me and I did remember
when I was at Barstool one of the girls
used to work there it was my friend
Sammy from campega like a million years
ago and I did remember and she came up
to you with a face in your face and said
do you remember me she was like Sammy
for me I'm like excuse me for me yeah
like I remember completely yeah she
didn't bury the lead okay that's fine
but like going up to someone do you
remember me
yeah
no I feel that especially like for
somebody who suffers from like you know
memory loss it's not it's not gonna work
and for people who suffer from time
blindness like it's just not we could
have been times
it's not inclusive to do that it's
ableist for sure ableist as hell
all right well that's our show feels
like the last show of the week but it's
not we'll literally be back here
tomorrow yeah
um so thanks so much for listening to
the Joe's Monday Morning Show where we
deliver the fast five stories you need
to remember the Friday on YouTube so
watching this on YouTube is nobody
subscribing this video thumbs up also
available Spotify
have a great day happy Thursday and
we'll see you tomorrow love ya bye